حوالي الفيقه الا في تركيا وسوريا نتيجه
الزلزال المدمر زلزال ثاني يضرب تركيا
وارتداداته تصل الى العراق ولبنان
تغريده بحث هولنديه تنبا بوقوع الزلزال
المدمر تثير جدلا واسعا
طابت اوقاتكم هذه الاخبار وغير هذا ننقلها
لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
في اكبر زلزال تشهده البلاد منذ نحو 100
عام اعلنت السلطات التركيه عن مقتل 1014
شخصا على الاقل واصابه اكثر من خمسه الاف
جروح نتيجه الزلزال الذي ضرب وسط البلاد
صباح اليوم الاثنين بقوه 7.9 درجه على
مقياس الاخضر مراسل العربيه والحدث هذا
بان الولايات التركيه شهدت اكثر من 66 هزه
ارتداديه اعقبتها الزلزال العنيف مشيرا
الى تضرر اكثر من عشر ولايات وانهيار اكثر
من
1800 مبنى في البلاد استمرار الجهود
الانقاذ في البحث عن اعداد لا حصر لها من
العالقين تحت الانقاض
الى سوريا حيث تضاربت المعلومات حول حجم
الاضرار وعدد الضحايا الزلزال الذي ضرب
تركيا ووصلت اثاره المدمره الى الاراضي
السوريه لكن المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
اعلن عن مقتل
812 شخصا على الاقل في عموم مناطق البلاد
نتيجه الزلزال اضافه الى اصابه المئات
بجروح مختلفه مشيرا الى ان هناك المئات من
العائلات تحت انقاض المنازل المدمره في
معظم مدن وبلدات الشمال السوري وتحدث
المرصد عن سقوط مباني بشكل كامل وجزئي في
58 قريه وبلده ومدينه غالبيتها ضمن مناطق
شمال غرب سوريا
بعد ساعات قليله من وقوع الزلزال المدمر
اعلنت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
انها قامت بتسجيل زلزال ثاني مركزه كهرمان
مرعش جنوب شرق البلاد بقوه 7.6 درجه
ظهر اليوم الاثنين وسائل اعلام اللبنانيه
وسوريا وعراقيه نقلت ان بعض السكان شعروا
ظهر اليوم بهزه ارضيه جديده حيث اوضحت
وكالتهم انباء النظام السوري ان هزه ارضيه
وقعت في دمشق واللاذقيه وعدد من المحافظات
فيما اشارت شبكه الاعلام العراقي الى ان
عددا من السكان في الموصل ودهوك واربيل
شعير وشعروا به هزه ارضيه خفيفه
اظهرت مقاطع فيديو وصور من سوريا وتركيا
حجم الاضرار التي لحقت بالعديد من المدن
نتيجه الزلزال العنيف الذي ضرب تركيا
ووصلت ارتدادته الى دول الجوار المشاهد
التي التقطها المسعفون واشخاص اخرون
وتداولها رواد مواقع التواصل رصدت انهيار
مباني شاهقه في مدن تركيا جنوب شرقي
البلاد ومن هذا المبنى في مدينه ملاطيا
فيما انتشرت مقاطع اخرى لعائلات سوريه
تبحث عن افرادها وسلطات دمار المخيف
واخرون يطلبون المساعده لانقاذهم من الموت
كما اظهرت مقاطع ماساويه اخرى لحظه انتشار
العالقين تحت الانقاض
في خبرنا الاخير اتداول رواد السوشيال
ميديا تغريده مثيره للجدل لباحث توقع قبل
ايام زلزال تركيا وذكر الدول التي ستتاثر
بهذا الزلزال الخبير الهولندي والباحث في
شؤون الزلازل فرانك هوجربيتس توقع بالضبط
قبل ثلاثه ايام بدقه في تغريده له على
حسابه في موقع تويتر قائلا عاجلا ام اجلا
سيضرب زلزال بقوه 7.5 درجه سيضرب المنطقه
المحيطه بجنوبي ووسط تركيا والاردن وسوريا
ولبنان فيما قال ناشطون ردا على هذه
التغريده ان العديد من تنبؤات الباحث
الهولندي كانت خاطئه لكن توقعاته حول
زلزال سوريا وتركيا
كانت دقيقه بشكل لافت